the Joe Rogan experience what do you do
now at Kyle first of all how old you 20
you look great right thank you great
haircut - thank you yeah I like it how
old you really I'm working on being 20
joe going back yeah
I'm 50 - are you older than me I'm
working out we're both working good how
about you stick with that I don't want
to be judged based on my age I
understand how often you train these
days often do I train almost every day
almost every day just doing something
differently yeah doing something mostly
kettlebells or mostly for the last
several years with I suppose last
several month were kind of experimental
doing something else but for the last
several years pretty much has been
nothing but swings and and dips just one
of my protocols it's a very particular
anti glycolytic protocol and i
glycolytic means well the kind of thing
we just discussed it just swings in dips
yeah why why that combination trying to
be minimalist pretty much and trying to
cover as much base as possible also
trying to do things that my body likes
but the swings are I would argue that
the swing is the most beneficial
exercise anybody can do because you will
again your training power your training
your fast fibers you're developing
mitochondria in the fast fibers you are
training your connective tissues and you
know you're getting your cardio as well
it's not you know it's not focused on
that but you have that side effect the
dip is you know kind of coverage what's
been missing I like the idea of very
minimus general strength protocols that
just have pretty much a hip hinge and
and the press that's that's a preface
well chin ups or things along those
lines
sure is great I'll do him some time but
you will find to your surprise that if
you do swings powerfully and if you do
dips or push-ups powerfully chances are
you're not going to lose your chips
really chances are for most people
here's something to keep in mind what is
general training versus specific
training so in Russian sports science
there is a concept of general training
versus special training special means
sports specific pretty much
so the general straight general training
can be strengthened to be something else
gives you foundation for everything else
and it's characterized by high degree of
carryover so for example if you decide
to do barbell squats you know for a fact
that you're gonna jump higher you can
run fast you're gonna hit harder and so
on and so forth if you decide to go leg
extensions you can be sure that you're
gonna get better at leg extensions
that's it so general exercises are the
ones that are fairly simple to
performing if you to give you the
greatest possible carryover so that's
what you do and then after that you
start editing you more specific stuff so
let's say that you know you would
increase the number of chin-ups you want
to do what you got to do chips so that's
a specific practice absolutely
so Jennifer great one of the things that
I noticed that I thought was really
weird was when I started doing
kettlebells things that I wasn't doing I
got stronger at yeah like I wasn't doing
dips for a long time like I didn't do
them for months and months and I was
just doing kettlebells I was just doing
cleans and presses snatches swings a
bunch of different squat protocols
overhead squats my dip went through the
roof but it was so strange it was like
we call this the what the hell effect so
that type of carryover some of it we
can't understand some words we can
explain some which we can't but yeah
we've had the kettlebell swing for
example increase the performance of
world champion power lifters and top
marathon runners at the same time it's a
very bizarre thing and again someone we
talk and decipher some with second but
hey we'll take it right what do you
think is going on there if you had a
guess cuz okay so it's a number of
different things one is the type of the
type of breathing patterns that we use
for example for endurance that for that
helps strength and endurance so we use
this
Soraya's breathing that increases your
strength on exhalation so that pretty
much increases your strengths at any
kind of exertion whether it's punching
or lifting and at the same time we are
also training our muscles that
inspiration muscles inhalation muscles
as well and so developing developing
these muscles is really important for
your performance so that's just one of
the aspects in other aspects is the well
this is kind of interesting mr. Haney
was a coach for Danny Thompson Donny
Thompson is he broke the 3,000 pound
total record in in powerlifting some
years back so I'd known Donny for some
time so Donny kept hurting his back and
his deadlift was stuck so we met I
showed her some kettlebell stuff he
started doing that invented a couple of
cool things of his own as well so nine
months later he added about 70 pounds to
deadlift 100 pounds to his benchpress
said the total record and what's what
his coach said interesting he said
kettlebells work the muscles without
killing them it's kind of interesting so
it appears to be that the particular
stimulus that you have it's there's
always a positive and there's always a
negative when you're training right so
there's something good that's happening
it's also something that's holding you
back you have to recover so it seems to
be that nature of whatever things that
happens within the muscle is positive
more than negative and I think part of
it is very well those ballistic loading
the body adapted extremely extremely
well part of it has to do the particular
training protocols we have because we
produced the right amount of acid but
not too much acid a lot of trainees in
the kind of a puffed fitness world
they're just enamored with burn like oh
go for the burn yeah Fred Hatfield dr.
Fred hatch will have a great line so
Hadfield was the first lifter to squat a
thousand pounds in competition and he
was just a brilliant sports scientist
brilliant coach he said do you like burn
light a match yes people are dissing a
murder with a burn so again the loading
protocols we have is such that you have
the right amount of that of that
stimulation not excessive because what
happens you have too much lactic acid
right is here's what happens well many
many things happen we don't have the
time to discuss this on the show but
most of them are really rather negative
some positive Muslim read the negative
but for sure they the making work it
makes you more sore for sure people like
to say well soreness is just caused by
eccentric loading and that's it has
nothing do lactic acid well eccentric
loading does contribute to that
absolutely but acid does as well he
doesn't literally burn holes in your
muscle but it does stimulate lysosomes
something kind of eats up defective
components of the cell to function and
you also have this spike of free
radicals and so that free radicals
damaged cell membranes as well
so with what we do we try to and plus
there's other stuff happens like body
starts producing ammonia which is toxic
and depletes your ATP so all this things
start going there's really sideways so I
think the nature of what you do with
kettlebells a special fuse the correct
protocol is you just optimize this
metabolic metabolic environment to get
exactly what you want well there are
some other things too like in your case
we're pressing and for dips I challenge
anybody to find a pressing exercise
that's by mechanically more perfect for
the shoulder than the caliber military
press
it's perfect range of motion is perfect
great stretch great contraction great
just absolutely perfect so someone were
to get some we don't but hey what the
hell effects will take it right
[Applause]